well Peter Thursday wishes me could be
here tonight he actually never travelled
to the United States a country
he has above all known and loved through
cinema Pierrot is passionate about his
work and therefore it is with great
excitement that he received the new of
this unexpected honorary award a robot
for which he thank all of the Academy
and which he accepts also thanks that
through this recognition the Academy
intended to Bistro recognition to all
those who work with behind the camera
Piero Piero wishes to thank Deborah
Landis for the dedication with which
changed our work through Piero is not
here at his table are many colleagues
and fellow companions with which he
feels to share this recognition and Rose
million can onero Gabriella Pascucci
Dino Tripathy Jo of T Renly costume
house and Carlo fagioli
but Piero asked me an actress to collect
this price because he believes that the
work of a costume designer is mainly
dedicated to us the action the actors I
suspect that it shows me because a thing
he made me suffer a lot during the 10
film with did together even if he said
something different dear Claudia please
go to pick up my prize
you they will be Angelica and Bianca the
leopard and Lavazza Visconti and Bologna
and all the Italian cinema to which I
have devoted my entire career and we
have of Pietro
Oh Piero thank you very much